on l'a vu nelson mandela et donc à paris
pour participer à une grande conférence
sur le sida qui réunit cinq mille
chercheurs venus de 120 pays
l'ancien président sud africain est venu
défendre la lutte contre le sida en
afrique et dans ce domaine la route est
encore longue
sophie mais elle eric mézil partout où
il va
l'homme déclenché des standing ovations
nelson mandela ancien président de
l'afrique du sud
ancien prix nobel de la paix émouvant a
presque 85 ans devant un parterre de
scientifiques venus échanger leurs
connaissances sur le sida
aujourd'hui il se faisait le porte
parole de l'afrique toute entière face à
ce fléau et plus généralement des hommes
et des femmes trop pauvre pour avoir
accès aux soins sur les 26 millions de
personnes mortes du sida depuis 20 ans
nous at il rappelé 95% habiter dans les
pays en voie de développement
à l'issue de son discours une poignée de
militants d'act up qui avait pris le
soin de prévenir nelson mandela ont
scandé ensemble traiter les 6 millions
ou sont les 10 milliards référence aux
six millions de malades qui ont le plus
besoin de soins et aux 10 milliards
comme il ya deux ans par l'onu comme
aide annuelle a engagé dans la lutte
contre le sida
on est encore loin du compte et ce n'est
pas nelson mandela qui dira le contraire